the not only Bill Burr's story was I was
I went on Howard Stern and I was again
terrified you know they sit in this
little out room outside you probably
maybe have done yeah right so you sit in
the room and then they talk about you
before they bring you in right right and
you sit there and and you're just with
me and my publicist and he's just going
on and on and on and you know you know
thing and you're like oh God okay bring
them in yeah it can go either way oh
yeah and I walked in he says a Carrot
Top and I said how's it going he goes
you're you're like a normal guy and I
said what do you think he said I got to
be honest I don't know I thought you're
some [ __ ] weird freak dude I mean I'm
a freak dude but yeah but you know it
could have been more love and so it was
going great and he says do you know do
you know who Bill Burr is and I said uh
no he says really play the bill I
haven't it's great play The Bill Burr
thing
so it's Bill Burr just [ __ ] going
coals on me I mean just right I mean
just bad and then it ends and he goes so
you don't know Bill and I said well I I
guess I probably you know I don't think
I want to meet him now like it was just
it was horrible and then when I finally
meet him he was like dude I am so sorry
like he came and hugged me and said I
was just [ __ ] you know comic to come
he's [ __ ] around but I love he and he
he did he came to the show we're great
friends now right but but it was it was
it was horrifying when he played the
tape I'm like okay yeah when I first
started doing stand up uh Dane Cook was
like a mentor to me we would um like go
out to the comedy clubs and and you know
he would do his set then I would do my
set and then we would sit down he would
give me notes but he would do his set
and then I would do my set and or
everybody's Versa and he would just be
the most vicious like terrible like
meanest like he would just reduce used
me to like the size of a thimble and and
then like bring me on stage you know you
know like and and maybe it was it was so
weird like it's with love yeah you know
yeah crazy it's called Stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of Amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on Amazon and
buy Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude